welcome back to las vegas now well
there's nothing better than a good steak
and a delicious bourbon to go along with
it right well you can get both of those
at twin creek steakhouse at the
silverton which is reopening tomorrow
and joining us today is executive chef
ashley archer and general manager
michael yi thank you guys so much for
being here thanks for having us of
course congrats on the reopening i have
been to the restaurant before i know how
delicious it is but you guys are going
all out what can we expect as you guys
are back and probably bigger and better
than ever right absolutely well one of
the things is
you won't recognize it because it's gone
through a facelift over the last year so
with that facelift what we've done is we
completely reimagined everything from
our server steps of service to our menu
items to our bourbon flights even our
sangria has a unique twist on it yeah
i'm looking at that sangria over there
let's talk about the drinks before we
even get to the food what are some of
your specialties what do we have here so
one of our
specialties is the sangria we uh infused
that in red wine and makers mark 46
for several days
and uh the flavors are just showing
really great right now wow well sangria
weather bourbon sign me up and let's
talk about some of this food that we
have here all looks delicious i've had
the steak when i've been in but let's
talk about a little bit of everything
you have on the menu well first things
first we this is our seafood tower so
our seafood tower again we reimagined it
reinvented it it comes with a pound
pound and a quarter whole lobster we
have some crab cocktail claws we have
some marist crab which is basically a
barrel meat it's just of king crab we
have jumbo shrimp and we have our
oysters which changes depending on the
seasonality
and then over here we have our tomahawk
for two so it's our creekstone farm
tomahawk
that we
you know put underneath our 800 degree
broiler and get a nice char on it it
comes with grilled asparagus topped with
bernays the steak's topped with truffle
butter it comes with a red wine demi and
just if that isn't enough we went ahead
and did butter poached lobster mashed
potatoes oh my gosh you had me at
truffle butter but now i'm looking at
these mashed potatoes and they look
amazing
if this is just a preview of what's on
the menu i can only imagine when it's
like actually in the restaurant and hey
if bourbon isn't your thing you guys
also have a wine list too right
absolutely and the uh
with along with everything else we've
improved the the beverage program and
our wines
mostly california reds
and the selections are
are just amazing well you can't go wrong
can i have a red in one hand and a
bourbon in the other and it's going to
be a fun night and just how does it feel
to reopen after all this time of being
closed i'm sure it's going to be a
really special moment tomorrow i think i
think tomorrow is the uh you know sort
of the pinnacle for us we've done all
the background work and we've we trained
the staff and we've done these trial
feedings and and really raise the
expectations and tomorrow just to be
able to open those doors share it with
the public and be able to just you know
start the new journey is really
invigorating and really exciting and i
mean we couldn't be happier
this is the one restaurant that we've
been waiting and waiting and waiting
to to be able to unveil again and um so
we're we're all super super excited i
think we're all on cloud nine we're kind
of running on adrenaline a little bit
maybe a little bit
but we're gonna make it yes well
congrats on the reopening i feel like
you guys should grab a glass and do
little cheers to the camera because this
is an exciting moment so be sure to go
to twins creek steakhouse at the
silverton i can vouch that it's
delicious thank you guys for being here